I gathered some of the most hyped beauty
products to test out for myself and
these are my least favorite from this
month this is the statue Beauty lip
liner stain it's a peel off lip liner
that leaves the stain behind the first
time I did it the stain was just kind of
noticeable I used the nude shade but it
looked way more pink than nude I did it
again to see if I could make it more
pigmented and it kind of worked I could
definitely see it more but I feel like
it just looked patchy I feel like this
is a good idea but not a great execution
this is the KVD good apple full coverage
transfer proof serum Foundation I have
to address this immediately this is like
four Shades too light for me this has
pretty full coverage it looks okay over
my more textured areas it didn't look
cakey and it felt lightweight on my skin
it's a very okay Foundation I just know
that 42 dollars is a lot for it